hey guys it is the sixth of October my
name is just and here's the things that
are happening in gaming a lake on the
Xbox store has suggested that halloween
themed items are coming to overwatch
well if it is not yet announced any
official plans for a halloween event but
a Reddit user posted a picture of a
listing for halloween loot boxes the
description on the page outlines what
types of items you'll find much like
those that arrive during the summer
olympics event and the 100 new items
will include covering skins highlight
intros emotes and victory poses and
voice lines and player icons no start
date is listed but the description
mentioned the event will end on November
one next up Mafia 3 is arriving tomorrow
but it will be capped at 30 frames per
second on all platforms unfortunately
that does include PC but a post on the
official mafia website suggests they are
working to provide better performance
options it reads we're currently working
on an update for PC that will give
players the option to play mafia 3 at
higher frame rates will share more
details about the update and when you
can expect it to arrive very soon 2k and
developer hangar 13 have also said
they're keen to your feedback on what
performance adjustment options are
important to you as they're considering
additional post-launch improvements for
PC finally in very very very exciting
news which we kind of already knew but
is still super cool Beyond Good and Evil
2 is officially in development a post
arrived on the Beyond Good and Evil
facebook page which read if you've been
waiting for news about Beyond Good and
Evil well here you go we're delighted to
confirm that Michelle on cell is
currently working with the Ubisoft
montpelier studio on a new Beyond Good
and Evil game the Mobilio studio has
contributed to a number of the company's
previous games including Tom Clancy's
Ghost Recon wildlands and arraignment
origins Beyond Good and Evil 2 was first
announced in 2008 and has been on and
off the radar since then that is
everything I have you today do let me
know what you cared about head to
gamespot for stories on battlefield 1
and pokemon go and I'll have the top
five stories of the entire week already
free tomorrow